to start talking about how awesome you
are yeah you know and then one of the
guys looks at me and he goes where does
it say that in the Bible I'm like what
does it say what he says where does it
say that Christians have to feed the
Homeless and I gave him the Bruce Willis
like what the [__] yeah Adam and in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast we are finally in the
studio now the studio looks a little
familiar to you if you're watching this
on the video side it's because this is
the same Studio
behind the food same dudes behind the
Food Studio
um so I'm back here I just moved into
the new spot and let me tell you
something man already about to throw
fists with the neighbors you pieces of
[__] I'll tell you this man
the pla look when you guys move so much
you definitely get a feel for like what
a shitty and like a good landlord is
yeah so the current place that I live
right now or that I lived in uh before
literally just a week ago though that
was they were probably the best
landlords I've ever had and some of the
the nicest neighborhood I've ever lived
in right everybody knows each other's
first and last name they say good
morning uh they they watch after your
place if you leave on vacation right uh
they'll watch your plans for you it's
really kind of crazy like it's one of
those uh neighbors that you see uh on TV
right right so you walk down the street
hey Mr Soderbergh yeah look straight up
like that so now let's fast forward to
the new place that I move into all
Chinese people
it's a different Dynamic it's a very and
look we're not talking about Chinese
Americans we're talking about recent
immigrant Chinese people which is you
know this place is a little cheaper a
lot cheaper actually
and there's nothing wrong with that but
I'm so used to like a friendly Dynamic
and you know when you're an immigrant
Chinese person you kind of just mind
your own business yeah like that's
that's typically The Stereotype that you
have with Asian people is that they
always just mind their own business
whether it's a good or bad thing so the
first day that I move in I see a few
people with their kids or whatever
whatnot I'm moving in I'm like hi my
name is David I'm your new neighbor and
they just look at me and they just walk
by
bro who are you talking to me yeah I'm
not used to that type of [__] I'm like
okay maybe that's just them and so I I
see this other older lady and I'm like
hi she just stares at me and just walks
right by me again oh God okay this is uh
this is a different Dynamic here so the
day that I move in
or the first day that I start to move in
um you're not supposed to park your car
in front of the garage because it's a
really narrow space
um there's you know fire signs
everywhere so there's a the person in
front of me constantly Parks the car in
the front and our landlord who I [__]
hate already by the way said that you're
not supposed to park there or you'll
you'll get your car towed so but I told
him hey we're moving things in so we're
gonna have to park the temporary he's
gonna go that's fine so
there's a neighbor
already pissed me off
so they parked the car that I parked my
car that I'm only gonna park it there
for like three or four minutes just to
unload and then move my car away so this
Neighbor comes down and he wants to get
his car past us right even though this
other car he's parked their car there
for three [__] hours it's not even
supposed to be there yeah he clearly
sees me moving my [__]
so you could already tell when somebody
assumes that you don't speak English
right so in the whole neighbor and I
understand because the majority of the
people in the neighborhood don't speak
English yeah so the guy comes up
and by the way there's two exits he
doesn't have to exit this way he could
just exit the other [__] way right
because he clearly sees me moving in and
so the guy comes up he goes hello hello
like that and by the way it's 100
degrees like in L.A now yeah I'm already
irritated as [__] I'm pissed as [__] he
goes hello you got swamp ass cause it's
[__] sweaty yeah irritated and I look
at it I'm like I already know that tone
you assume I don't speak English right
and so I look at him and he goes
can't park car here oh God he does the
Caveman talk can't park car here and no
Park here exactly so you know me being
the jackass that I am I'm already
getting [__] angry and then of course
I go from Angry to I'm gonna make the
funniest situation out of this and I go
why buy me no [__] all right yeah I
speak [__] English dude God he goes
you don't see me moving in my stuff
right now this car has been here for
three hours so why the [__] are you
yelling at me
and the guy freezes yeah so what's the
[__] problem and I'm like listen I'm
your new neighbor you probably shouldn't
talk to me like that yeah I was like I
can move the car you don't have to talk
to me he goes oh I'm sorry it's just a
lot of people Park their car here I was
like I understand but you off the jump
started yelling at me yeah I was like
Doc I just moved in you can't wait three
minutes or maybe if you would have just
talked to me and said like hey I need to
get my car through here I would have
just moved you doing this whole waving
your hand in my [__] face like five
inches from my [__] face it's not
gonna help us get along the guy's dead
silent no Asian person has talked to me
for longer than 15 seconds or at all so
this guy is [__] dead quiet he's not
saying anything I was like listen I I
want to be a good neighbor to you
because we're going to be here for at
least a year yeah but I don't appreciate
you doing that and on top of that man
you could see there's another exit on
the other side even if this is
inconvenient for you right now you could
have just left on the internet he
doesn't want to go in reverse exactly
doesn't even apologize he goes okay I'll
just wait four or five minutes I'm like
cool I was like so we're good he's like
yeah I'll just wait and I'm like
no no I'm sorry yeah because I'm being
super combative I want in a [__]
apology yeah I want a [__] apology so
he goes oh no I'm sorry he goes that's
my bad I said no no I wanna I'm sorry
because like listen straight up right
now I'm actually [__] pissed so once
again quiet looking at me he goes all
right I'm sorry I was like cool I got
you back as your neighbor my name is
David whatever whatever you need just
let me know but next time just don't
talk to me like that yeah and I haven't
seen him since I think he's already
scared of me avoiding you yeah yeah dude
man I was talking about being a good
neighbor man I've had this experience
last week actually
um
you know
if you remember back in college there's
a thing called like campus ministry
right and those people are we've we've
talked about it before like
um campus ministry people who like want
to preach or like talk to people about
Jesus on campus and stuff like they are
what do you call it
Relentless right they won't take no for
an answer so before in the past like
these kids would come up to me and be
like hey uh do you want to join a Bible
study and be like nah it's all right
hey stop
[__] no so but this one time I had
lost my airpods so I had to wear my uh
the big ones what are they called
right so you know I they're over the
ears I'm clearly just minding my own
business and these two kids are walking
by me and he tapped me on the shoulder
straight up I don't like that I don't
like that and then they're like oh and I
have noise canceling on so I I take my
headphones out I'm like can I help you
like Hey we're on our way to a Bible
study do you want to come with us
and I was like nah you're like oh um I
mean why not you know and so why not I'm
the wrong guy that's what I said yeah
you caught me at like at a wrong time
and I'm not the right person and they're
like oh well why not they're not they're
not taking no for an answer right so I'm
like I'm an apostate and they're like
well what's an apostate so I'm like I
used to be a believer but now I'm not
anymore right and then they go that's
perfect that's exactly why you should
come to our Bible study
it was really annoying it's like Hey
listen
you as somebody who is who is supposed
to be an apostle right so you're trying
to get me closer to Christ I literally
said I'm an apostate and you don't know
what the [__] that is are you out of
your mind
it's like
so yeah I mean they're not taking no for
an answer
and they're like that's exactly why you
should come and I was like no that's
exactly why I shouldn't because I'm not
gonna have a good time there man like I
don't wanna I'm not trying to toot my
own horn but like I know the Bible man I
don't I don't want to go and then once
again they're like but that's why you
should come like this goes on like
and I'm like taking on the challenge now
I made a New Year's resolution this year
that I would stop [__] like stop
using my Bible knowledge yeah to [__] on
all the Christians but I [__] flick
that [__] out the window and I was like
look man like I used to be a minister
like in Ministry for 10 years I used to
be a missionary right I used I did all
that [__] man I just don't believe it
anymore like you do okay and then once
again that's why you should come to our
Bible study and so I ramped it up
I was like look man when I came back
from these missions and I saw the way
American Christians behave like where
you don't want to feed the poor you
don't want to help the sick you don't
want to help the addicted I I thought it
was just all [__] because why the
[__] am I doing and I start cussing
right and I'm like so why would I want
to be in a Bible study with you guys do
you do that you know I all I see you
guys doing is asking people come to
Bible study you know you even haven't
even told me how awesome Jesus is yet
yeah you know you just start talking
about how awesome you are yeah you know
and then one of the guys he looks at me
and he goes where does it say that in
the Bible I'm like what does it say what
where does it say that Christians have
to feed the Homeless
and then I gave him the Bruce Willis
like what the [__] yeah Adam and then
the guy standing next to him elbowed him
and then I was like I asked are you
being like sarcastic or do you not know
and he's like no I want to know where to
say that in the Bible
in my head I want to be like you want me
to go to Bible study with you you don't
[__] know that [__] yeah
but I just said Matthew 25 says that
when we die we're going to get judged by
God and he's going to ask us hey when I
was hungry why didn't you feed me when I
was sick why didn't you take care of me
yeah when I was naked why didn't you
clothe me I'm [__] reciting this this
thing and then we're gonna say well
Jesus when did you ask us to do that he
says every time you looked at the least
of these and you ignored them you did
that to me he's essentially saying when
you look into the eyes of the broken and
the homeless you should be seeing Jesus
behind their eyes and you would love on
them like as if Jesus lives in them
and I'm not and I don't see that in you
yeah you know and I don't [__] want
to do that [__] because Christians who
claim they're Christians don't do that
[__] just like him yeah and literally in
the Bible Jesus doesn't say who goes to
hell and and where except Here If you
deny these people you're going to hell
yeah right and so I was like and if I go
to your Bible study I'm gonna go there
and talk [__] about you guys and my
experience right now I'm gonna sit on
everyone in that [__] room I'm gonna
you know interrupt and give my [__]
opinions on this all right you don't
want me there
and then they finally relented because I
had to [__] on them like that yeah yeah
and then I was like I'll see you guys in
Hell by the way I said this too I'm
gonna go on a podcast and I'm gonna talk
[__] about both of you guys I said that
and they're like okay and they walked
away well this is the problem right
and you'll see a lot of YouTube videos
and YouTube shorts that kind of do this
where they expose okay and you know from
from a non-religious standpoint right
one of the hardest things about I think
being a part of
like a Christian Community is that
there's so many people that are so die
hard for Christ without knowing the
Bible yes right like why are you doing
this that is the frustrating part right
that's why like even though like I
attend church uh casually right and I
you know we've we've spoken about this
where I I do it because
obviously as a believer I'm not exactly
the Exemplar yeah uh I mean I'm not an
Exemplar person to represent the
religion right but then maybe it's
because I grew up going to church my
whole life that it fulfills a certain
part that I need right
um and that's just a whole separate
topic but for a lot of people out there
who are going out to preach about God
but you know nothing about the religion
you are going to get [__] ripped
apart yeah and you're seeing this a lot
so for example there you say what you
want about a lot of Muslim people right
but when I meet somebody who is like a
devout Muslim do they know the Quran
back and forth inside and out they're
about it they are about it and I
actually seldom meet a lot of Christians
who do that yeah and so they'll try to
and you could find Clips on this online
which I don't really like per se because
they tend to cut out the whole
conversation they only put out stuff
that makes them look good yeah but
either way like they're trying to combat
somebody who knows their religion inside
and out when they have a very
lackadaisical understanding of the
religion that they're trying to defend
event and this is what happens so
somebody in this case they come out and
they say because originally what you did
was you opposed their kindness and
they're used to being kind and having
that reciprocated back to them yeah so
this individual didn't get that so
immediately what he what does he do he
actually throws out Christianity and he
goes straight to anger where does it say
that in the Bible right and then now
that he got his response back you didn't
get an apology you didn't say oh maybe I
need to research this again he just goes
you know what this guy's a [__] crazy
person you walk away but literally the
worst example of a religion that you're
trying to get somebody to convert to
which is a problem and they had I had
this a lot in college campuses you know
we've talked about how there was a a
group called uh Korean Christian
Crusaders for Christ right first of all
shorten that [__] up yeah kccc yeah yeah
and they're always Korean fobs too yeah
I'm from okay a Triple C
I love Jesus empathy would always have
these arbitrary rules yeah right no
touching no kissing
um no holding hands you can't have a
girlfriend or boyfriend until you're a
sophomore or a junior in college
policing what you post on social media
like what is this [__] you know what
I'm saying so if you're going to do that
you better be a clear example of the
religion because if not I'm going to
call you out on your [__] I mean
that's the problem with today's uh
evangelism let's say like prophesizing
and like reaching out to people they're
not going out to like say hey this is
how awesome Jesus is hey this is what
Jesus can do for your life they're
saying look at how awesome we are look
at how cool we are and you want to be
part of us and you want to leave your
sinful and then so they judge you for
your sinfulness oh my God so this
happened last Sunday too once again
broke my [__] New Year's resolution
on Sunday I went to church after church
I wasn't doing [__] so I was like I'm
gonna go watch mission impossible so I'm
putting my by myself and so I go to the
Chinese Theater because I love that
theater
and so that's Hollywood Boulevard so
there's all these like uh tourists and
stuff and the Chinese Theaters is where
they have all those Stars put us put
their hand prints and Footprints under
cement
but right in front of the theater
there's a group of these men you know on
the microphone screaming with their
signs and pickets
like calling everyone Sinners and like
how God hates homosexuals and all that
and then I always just ignore them you
know like I went to the Anime Con and
they were out there to any major
sporting event they'll be out there
right just ignore them
but for some reason because maybe I had
time
I witnessed them just
[__] verbally abused the this Muslim
couple
right because they were just standing
there watching them and then he went on
the bike like who are you what are you
guys doing here what do you what do you
believe in then I mean I can't hear them
but on the mic I hear Muhammad Muhammad
says liar Muhammad is a fake you're a
sinner
and something just ticked in me and I
went to that Muslim couple
and then I was like Hey I just came from
church and I'm just so sorry about these
people yeah yeah right and then that guy
started yelling at me he's a liar he's a
sinner Jesus is not in him he is the
liar he's not a Christian
and then
I went off mind you this like I said
Hollywood Boulevard there's like
hundreds of people walking around and I
started screaming at the top of my lungs
at them about their judgment and they're
[__] they're the [__] Liars
nobody's [__] listening to you on the
[__] and I just assumed like you're
probably divorced or single or you you
so you hate women you hate all gays you
blame everything else for your problems
I'm screaming this yeah
right and then the guy changes mics with
someone else and then he starts healing
and then for the movie my throat is
partially yeah tag team well well
movie's about to start I just turn
around and walked away yeah but then I
honestly was a little confused as to how
I reacted but then in a sense I really
felt like that Muslim couple actually
felt thankful for me to actually be like
hey please don't listen to these people
you know and then it just makes me
[__] sick like
just so you know everyone else there
like when you say oh my church doesn't
do that hey you guys are under the same
umbrella yeah and if you walk down the
street and you see those people and you
don't say anything about how effective
that [__] is are ineffective rather
then you're a [__] coward too dog is
did you see that video clip of that lady
who was screaming at a college campus
about like getting your dick sucked
she was I might have I might have and
she was like the devil's gonna come
you're gonna meet a lady and she's going
to put her mouth on your penis
if you buy her one Margarita she will
spread her legs
[Applause]
she won't pounce right on your penis
after Three Margaritas she will grab
your penis and put it in her mouth
[Applause]
he will grab your penis and ran that
right up her anus
what happens
[Applause]
she will strap it on and take
it
she's gonna use her vagina and sit on
your [__] and then people understand
that everybody loves their [__] and I
don't think she fully understood what
she was doing they thought they were
like amen sister yeah that's one of the
funniest things ever but yeah
that's what I'm saying there's so many
I think that before you go ahead and you
wear this badge or whatever religion
that you're following right you do have
to understand that once you put yourself
out there like that now you leave
yourself up to judgment right right you
are now a a four like you're in the
Forefront of the representation of that
that religion right so if you see that
as a Christian and you see somebody
screaming at somebody who's Muslim right
or just doing things out of anger and
like casting their Stones right you
should probably say something yeah right
or if if this is what you're truly about
right because that's super hard to see I
mean obviously when you see like every
gay pride parade there's always going to
be that one group of people picketing
right they're always streaming like
sodomites will go to hell blah blah blah
blah hates F words yeah all that other
stuff right and they're usually drowned
out by clearly hundreds of thousands of
people yeah who are obviously against
what they do so that I think that's kind
of like nip in the bud but for to watch
that's kind of hard you know I mean like
you I definitely probably would have
like stepped in and apologize for them
in fact I screamed in my face I probably
wouldn't have scream because I'm just
too tired yeah but you know I can
understand from that point it's like
when you're just so sick of it you just
snap I had the energy that day yeah I
mean I I guess I'll give it up to that
uh episcopalians the Episcopal yeah but
they go to Pride parades with big like
I'm sorry signs like I'm sorry like your
father did this I'm sorry that I judged
you I'm sorry that we judge you and and
then so you can see there's videos and
like photos like of gay people going to
them and giving them hugs and like
having a cry like and that is the true
representation of the Gospel that is a
Redemption of of your relationship with
with these people like and that's
something that we need but like I said
Christians see what those guys are doing
and they don't speak up because there's
like I'm not them it's like but you they
claim you are them yeah so what do you
have to say you know dog I I've I've
definitely gotten like a rabbit hole of
watching some of the weirdest
um Christian YouTube shorts one of my
favorite ones of all time is the guy
that goes up on stage and he's just I
Believe In Christ
I don't like man anymore
turn around and tell those people
Kevin
I'm not gay no more I am delivered
I don't like men no more
I like women
women
I said women
I'm not gay I would not date a man I
would not care a person I would not put
on makeup I will
I will love
I am delivered and that boy is so gay oh
yeah I mean he's still like on social
media saying all you haters talking
about my hair but he's saying it's so
sassy
it's like stop lying to yourself man
yeah I think I'm gay and [__] but I'm
not gay I swear to God y'all for real
right now you think I'm gay I'm
delivered bro the [__] sass coming
out of you is unreal that [__] looks so
weird
um so you know uh
we had a producer
and she told me this story that was
[__] nuts so her her father
apparently was a very very famous like
gospel Pastor or some [__] like that I
don't know what it is exactly but he's
very well known and I think you can look
him up I I did at the time I didn't
really I don't remember his name or
anything but either way
so her obviously being gay was a sin she
actually went to like uh
sexuality Reformation oh the gay therapy
conversion therapy yeah she went through
like gay therapy conversion which I've
only heard of but I actually never met
somebody who actually went through it
now clearly didn't work because she is
gay as [__] yeah right so
she tells me that kids would go to these
camps during like gate conversion
therapy or whatever whatnot and they
would go willingly because it's just a
bunch of places
so they could [__] yeah so they could go
to this like conversion therapy camp and
they would just [__] each other's brains
out yeah through this whole thing so
it's like what the [__] were you
thinking of course that's going to
happen yeah that would happen during
church retreats
then stories their stories were [__]
nuts dude I so in my church there was a
guy I [__] hate this dude he and he
was a church leader and he actually
ended up hooking up with one of the one
of the students dear God of course right
yeah and so he was at the time I think
19 and the girl was 16. so she was
underage he's obviously you know a full
adult
and it was a [__] debacle dude it was
like Doc why the [__] would you do that
are you out of your [__] mind yeah
but anybody who has like this position
of power especially when it's like a
pretty girl these scumbags are going to
use that [__] yeah right use use their
you know religion to get a little closer
they're like you know what Jesus inside
you and so am I
[Music]
and so they actually hooked up and they
smashed and it was like a whole dramatic
thing in our [__] Church yeah but
that's what happened at the church a lot
and I'm not listen I'm not you know for
those of you who are Christian and you
hear these type of things it's not to
say that I'm hating on Christianity
itself but there are bad things that
happen that you should speak up on it
yeah it's not just like the Catholic
Church you know yeah like we're seeing
it in the Southern Baptist Church too
like they're getting flamed because they
have a history of hiding sexual abuse
and spiritual abuse too right like and
it's happening like right now they're
having a a bunch of people just left
that denomination dude I I don't know
how many times I've heard of the story
or the pastor ended up sleeping with
like the the Korean pianist yeah
like how often did that happen that
happened at so many churches where
somehow like the piano lady is always
hooking up with a passage did I so when
I got back from one of my missions
um usually I I'd come stop by La before
I went back home to Washington
and then it was just so happened that
weekend uh there was a wedding so they
invited me to come because the the youth
pastor was getting married
so okay I show up and I don't know
anybody there it's just like um cousin's
church and
my cousin's telling me he's like yeah
this wedding's a little weird actually
it's like because the youth pastor is
like 30 and he's marrying a 20 year old
right but it was like she used to be one
of the youth group kids oh that's that's
grooming dude yeah that's straight up
group and so I went to a wedding I I had
no idea about of a [__] grooming
victim yeah and so I was like oh my God
yeah it's so [__] weird like it's
weird how people think that that's okay
it's like well he was there for me like
of course he was there for you
manipulated the [__] out of you yeah
like at your lowest point and that's
where a lot of people come to religion
right it's like they're at a certain
point in their life where they feel that
something is missing right and you'll
find a lot of people who convert to
Christianity or whether it's Buddhism or
whatever religion they're at a certain
point in their life where they need
something uh to be answered that they
haven't been vulnerable exactly yeah and
you have these people in power and
Leadership that come in and they show
them this this feeling or emotion that
they haven't felt in years and that
suddenly becomes into a different
feeling right like oh this person
understands me this person gets me and
it's like I actually might be attracted
to this person and that person exploits
that it happens all the time and I call
this we said this on this podcast before
we call it the the church oppa yeah
right yeah AC starts playing you know
his typical Korean Christian chords on
the guitar the girl's like oh my god oh
but you're so cool I was like yeah you
know you should come over my house for
some Bible study yeah and all of a
sudden they start making out it would
happen all the [__] time [__]
scumbags like
when a girl like because they're in
their team they're going through puberty
they're having attraction and yeah they
get attracted older dudes like seriously
first you gotta rebuke that [__] then as
the [__] leader you gotta [__]
take yourself out of that [__]
situation yeah first place like even
I've wrote a thing where just on
Facebook where I was like hey you know
I've been bullied a lot and I'm
experiencing a bunch of this racist [__]
right now
so I was like if anybody else is going
through this right now I'd love to talk
and and help out and then there was this
15 year old girl dming me you know like
like hey you know I'm doing this and I
was like um no you should talk to this
Ani okay yeah you should talk to her
talk to her and then I DM that hey
told this girl to stop talking to me
yeah and then go talk to her she's going
through some stuff yeah right it's like
it's as simple as that yeah like even
high school teachers you could see
they'll just be like nope we're not
[__] doing that we're not going there
and then because you see the teachers
who get in [__] trouble it's like Oh
and it would happen a lot to it it's not
to say that you can't be there for
somebody who's younger right but when
somebody is like in their teens and
they're emotionally vulnerable those
emotions can get mixed up a lot and you
will get in trouble yeah right not to
say that even on let's say on the flip
side the the person who's in the
education like in the Educators position
that they have the ad or ill thoughts
but you also have to understand like as
a young teen girl or boy they're going
to be really emotional and they're going
to be [__] up so you could only
imagine what's going to happen I talked
about this too where there was a girl in
high school who fell in love with our
history teacher like she was in love
with him yeah and so when I asked her
like hey it was just like a casual
conversation I basically asked her like
oh who did she like and you know she was
being really awkward about it but she
when she said the person's name I was
like that's a teacher what yeah you know
and so for me I gave a heads up to that
teachers like hey like just to let you
know like the reason why this person's
tinging with you is because they're
actually in love with you I know like I
don't want you getting troubles weird as
[__] he goes hey thanks for letting me
know that and he actually told me thanks
for letting me know because it was just
so awkward yeah he's not dumb because he
was actually pretty young you know when
when I look back at it now he was only
let's see I was like what 16 I think he
was like 22 23. yeah so he wasn't that
much older so he's not dumb he knows and
so he's like he obviously had to kind of
navigate around it he didn't want to
make it awkward for her didn't want to
get people involved so he just kind of
had her somewhere else working with
somebody else instead but that that's
what would happen so whatever he was
also
um the teacher that was um
not what do you call it the person who's
in charge of a club
oh [__] I have no clue yeah yeah but you
know let's say you start like a
photography club right and then they'll
sign a teacher to manage that so he was
also part of that as well guess what she
she signs up for that as well I didn't
know you like photography yeah exactly
right so
um you know for him he could have gotten
trouble even though he didn't do
anything at all just because this girl
was madly in love with him yeah and when
you were young and you're super
impressionable like yeah I feel like I
knew a lot of girls who found older men
attractive because they had their [__]
together they were either making money
they could drive they had a car or
whatever and they like that Independence
that a man had and so they would fall in
love with these qualities that obviously
are attracted to you now because you
don't have it when you're a young person
you know man you go through Reddit too
people tell their stories about how once
they graduated they real they found out
one of their teachers married their
classmates and [__] weird weird as [__]
like they'll divorce their [__] wives
and abandon their kids to marry this
[__] 18 year old Korean Church
pianist
I had a crush on one of my science
teachers biology biology teachers I mean
um say she was cute and she was the prom
queen and the prom King was Drew Bledsoe
the quarterback yeah Drew Palazzo grew
up in Washington
um but the thing is that went away when
she started being a [__] [__] I
don't know and a terrible teacher I was
like you know what I don't like this
person at all like I don't care I don't
like teachers were always
like if you had a good teacher too they
could really shape the way your life
would go yeah right because I remember
because I talked about this on my solo
podcast where you know I I genuinely
thought I was dumb as a kid and there
were certain teachers that kind of I
think they kind of knew like I had ADHD
yeah so they they were a lot more
understanding and empathetic right
because they could see the good
qualities in you that other people can't
because you're not traditionally uh
Smart in the way that people think you
should be yeah right so whether it's
people who could sit still and just you
know do their work in one go and they
would understand like oh this kid just
can't do it very well so those Educators
were the ones that kind of influenced me
in a positive way and I still keep in
contact with until this day yeah so you
know I can understand like this weird
I think I'm always like wary of people
in like a position of power now yeah
right how they speak to me how they
speak to you know people that I know
even kids so like I I plan to start
having kids hopefully you know next year
and now I'm thinking about who are the
people that I want around my children
right because I have a lot of friends I
have a lot of acquaintances there's a
lot of acquaintance I do not want around
my kids like we could drink together but
I don't want you talking to my kids
though yeah yeah you know yeah I think
the only positive teacher I could think
of was like my fifth grade teacher where
he saw like because I was an illustrator
I drew a lot and he went at a parent
teacher conference he was telling them
like hey I think I think Edward needs to
go to this other school it's for like
for gifted kids right and my parents
were like no
and then I remember they were pissed
they were mad at him for suggesting it
and like I remember looking at his face
and he was in utter disbelief looking at
me and he just felt I could see how sad
he was yeah he felt bad you know and
then subsequently like I tell all the
time like by the time I was in seventh
grade I had to move to the [__]
sticks and the boonies and
I always thought that story the first
word like anything this guy said to me
was I hate chaps right and then welcome
home the funny thing is I actually
became friends with him later and then
he he has like a missing tooth right and
I was like how'd you lose that tooth
it's like oh in fifth grade uh I got
drunk off vodka and then what the [__] I
rode my bicycle home and then fell on a
ditch and my tooth fell out it's like
you got drunken fifth grade he's like
yeah what about you yeah it's like I've
never touched alcohol at that point I
think a lot of immigrant Asian parents
um at the time and maybe even now uh
They Don't Really deal well with uh
somebody telling them that their kid
isn't quote unquote normal right because
they have this idea of what a stand-up
member in society is and what this kid
should be and what their potential is
yeah and so they think that everything
is within their control right so if I
tell my kid to do this this is what
they'll do and if they do this this is
how it'll turn out which kind of [__]
up a lot of young Asian American kids
because they academically they would do
really well right they would get the
Straight A's but they wouldn't really
intern anywhere they didn't do any
extracurricular activities yeah
um and they're very good on paper but
when it came to being in the workforce
they [__] suck and they assume that
just because they got this degree that
they would get a high paying job and it
never worked out that way right and
that's because that's what their parents
told them they didn't tell them how to
like hustle how to speak to people how
to get your way into like these very
into like these uh positions of power
and so for them
they kind of grow up a little [__] up
so when a teacher comes in and tells
them like hey your kid might need some
special help they go are you calling my
kid [__] yeah exactly that's what I
think my parents were thinking like like
school for special kids yeah like
special education like they would like
if you if somebody assessed their child
in school and they say hey they might
have like autistic Tendencies right
immediately no impossible you're not my
kid so instead of thinking of hey my kid
might need help so they could live their
best life they go I'm not gonna have a
dumb kid in my family yes and it's just
the worst thing ever and I saw this
happen a lot it happened a lot in church
where kid where parents wouldn't
understand that their kid won't be as
smart as this other kid it's okay
they'll be they'll excel in other things
that this other kid can and you see that
a lot in small infants some kids they um
they learn how to speak a lot faster but
then other kids are really good with
like building objects and understanding
like spatial stuff that that other kid
can't do people are talented in their
own different ways and I think that
sometimes with
you know traditional Asian parents they
only have one
um marker for what a successful human
being is and what intelligence it is so
if it's not straight A's if it's not not
getting in trouble at school then it's
like okay well this kid is dumb yeah my
parents pretty much through high
schoolers like we just give up we give
up on you
instead of acknowledging I wish my
parents would have gave up they were
just like ah I give up they say that to
me like I'm like okay so that's why I
just did whatever the [__] I wanted to
but like in in high school too speaking
of like good teachers
I don't think anybody like no teachers
actually stood up for me when like
clearly I was being bullied or like
having racist [__] said to me
but the weird thing was when I acted up
and I got into fights or I would throw
my [__] desk at somebody you know or
I hit somebody with a chair once too I
never got in trouble
like now that I'm older I think that the
teachers understood understood in their
meetings hey he's getting bullied so I
never got in trouble for these things
like so in like uh
uh keyboarding class like uh you know in
senior year you just take some [__]
classes so I'm just typing and [__] this
one kid who transferred from another
school because he uh was a what do you
call it
sex offender
yeah he is sexually assaulted somebody
at his old school They sent him to our
school
and so I moved yeah so everyone already
knew that about this kid and he ends up
in our keyboarding class
so I don't know why but he comes over my
shoulder to look at my screen and he I
forget what he says but he's just saying
some [__] and his breath smelled so
[__] bad right and then I just
watched that movie Snatch oh I took a
line from there I was like holy [__] did
you brush your teeth with dog [__] this
morning
and then he [__] spit in my face
you spit my [__] face with that
disgusting with that breath and so I
[__] shoved the [__] out of him and I
started punching him right and then he
put his hands up so I punched him right
in the [__] stomach right and then
immediately I turned around and I
grabbed my chair yeah with the wheels on
it yeah bam I [__] hit him right and
there's loud noise so everyone saw this
happening everyone's looking at it and
then the teacher comes out up from her
office she's like what's going on did he
touch you
but so it was like the Optics of it
though she comes in what's going on and
it's the sex offender and then the Asian
kid yeah and then he goes he hit me he's
hitting me with this chair and I just
said he spit on my face she goes oh no
you go to the principal's office and I
was like fine yeah and that kid got
expelled of course because it was like
one move he made one if he [__] up
once it was like one of those things and
I think all the teachers didn't want him
there either of course he's a [__]
sex offender yeah you know what I'm
saying that guy's weird huh is that
weird I can't believe [__] spit in my
face but yeah I mean I I experienced
that [__] man getting [__] spit on
like people throw trash on me and then
yeah I've you know the the desks with
the chairs attached how is that like an
immediate response to spit on somebody's
[__] face yeah just because your
breath stinks yeah he's like I'm French
this is my go-to move God damn you
[__] llama
well guys that wraps up this episode of
The Genius brain podcast
um you can catch Ed at edpark v p and
you guess she just brain every Sundays
at 12 p.m I hope you guys enjoyed this
podcast I know usually uh it's in the
other Studio but once again that studio
is gone
uh this is the first podcast with
another person in like [__] two weeks
and it was rough yeah doing a podcast by
yourself I forgot how hard it is to talk
to yourself right and to do it past like
10 minutes
and so like when I was doing the podcast
in the room I just remember I was like
I'm still talking and it's only been
three minutes yeah you're like you're
very self-aware you have to get one of
those uh mirror things in front of the
lens so you're actually looking at a
face at least right yeah I was I
remember just sitting sitting in the
room and I was like I feel like such a
loser yeah it's like a crazy person
people enjoyed it I think they said it
was like OG video Vibes that they got
but understand it's actually very
difficult to do that for a prolonged
period of time it's like an uncut Vlog
yeah you're kind of just rambling to
yourself like a crazy person yeah you
know what I'm saying yeah with all these
like intricate thoughts that stay in
your mind you're just saying it out loud
like a like literally a crazy person in
the street yeah you need someone to
bounce off of exactly well Dean has been
every Sundays at 12 pm and we'll see you
all next time peace